Imagine NASA announced today that
they found a bacteria on Mars,
weird avian fish in the oceans of Europa
and also ancient alien ruins on title.
Wouldn't that be great? Well,
no, it will be horrible news.
Devastating even it could mean that the
end of humanity is almost certain and
that it might be coming soon.
Why white would the most exciting
discovery of our lifetime be bad?
Let us imagine the development of life
from its inception to us today as a
flight of stairs,
the first day of his dad chemistry
that needs to assemble itself into self
replicating patterns, stable
and resilient, but also
able to change and evolve.
The second step is for our early
life to become more complex,
able to build more complicated structures
and use the available energy much more
efficiently.
On the next step,
the cells combined to
become multicellular beings,
enabling unbelievable variety
and further complexity.
The step above sees a species evolve.
Big brains enabling the use of tools,
culture, and shad knowledge, which
creates even higher complexity.
The species can now become the dominant
life form on its Panisse and change it
according to its needs. First shy attempts
to leave its planets are happening.
This is where we are now.
It's in the nature of life as we know is
to reach out to cover every new HSA cap
and since planets have a limited
carrying capacity and lifespan,
if a species wants to survive,
it will look for more places to spread to.
So the steps above the
current ones seemed logical,
colonize Europe so the system then spread
further to reach other stars to the
possible final step.
Becoming a galaxy wide civilization,
it's very likely that this is a
universal principle for civilizations,
no matter where they're from.
If a species is competitive and driven
enough to take control over its planet,
they'll probably not stop there.
We know that there are up to 500
billion planets in the Milky Way,
at least 10 billion earthlike planets.
Many have been around billions
of years longer than earth,
but we're observing zero
galactic civilizations.
We should be able to see something,
but there's nothing.
Space seems to be empty and dad,
this means something is preventing
living things from climbing the staircase
beyond the step we're on right now.
Something that makes becoming a
galactic civilization extremely hard,
maybe impossible.
This is the great filter,
a challenge or danger,
so hard to overcome that it eliminates
every species that encounters it.
There are two scenarios. One means
we are incredibly special and lucky.
The other one means we are doomed
and practically already dead.
It depends on where the
filter is on our staircase,
behind or ahead of us.
The scenario one,
the filter is behind us.
We are the first.
If the filter is behind us,
that means that one of the steps we
passed is almost impossible to take.
Which step could it be?
Is Life itself extremely rare?
It's very hard to make predictions about
how likely it is for life to emerge
from death things there is low consensus.
Some scientists think it develops
everywhere where the conditions are right.
Others think that earth might be the
only living place in the universe.
Another kind of data is the
step of complex animal cells.
A very specific thing happened on
their step and as far as we know,
it happened exactly once a primitive
hunter hill swallowed another salad,
but instead of devouring it,
the two cells formed a union.
The bigger sell provided shelter took
care of interacting with the environment
and providing resources.
While this water one used its new home
and free stuff to focus on providing a
lot of extra energy for its host.
With the abundant energy,
the host cell could grow more than before
and build new and expensive things to
improve itself. While the guest
became the powerhouse of the cell,
the cells make up every
animal on the planet.
Maybe there are billions of bacteria
covered planets in the Milky Way,
but not a single one.
Apart from us has achieved our
level of complexity or intelligence.
We humans feel very smart
and sophisticated with
our crossword puzzles and
romantic novels,
but a big brain is at first and foremost,
a very expensive evolutionary investment.
They are fragile.
They don't help in a
fistfight with a bath.
They cost enormous amounts
of energy and despite them,
it took modern humans 200,000 years to
get from sharp sticks to civilization.
Being smart does not mean
you get to win automatically.
Maybe intelligence is just not so great
and we're lucky that it worked out for
us.
Scenario to the filter is ahead of us.
Plenty of others died already.
A great filter before us is orders of
magnitude more dangerous than anything we
encountered so far.
Even if a major disaster killed most of
us or through us back thousands of years,
we would survive and recover
and if we can recover,
even if it takes a million years,
then it's not a great filter,
but just a roadblock to an eventual
galactic civilization on universal
timescales. Even millions of
years adjust the blink of an eye.
If a great filter really lies before us,
it has to be so dangerous,
so purely devastating and powerful
that it has destroyed most,
if not a full advanced civilizations
in our galaxy over billions of years.
A really daunting and
depressing hypothesis is that
once a species takes control
over its [inaudible], it's already
on the path to self destruction.
Technology is a good way to achieve that.
It needs to be something that's so obvious
that virtually everybody discovers it
and so dangerous that it's discovery
leads almost universally to an existential
disaster,
a large scale,
and you clear wall nanotechnology
that gets out of control.
Genetic engineering of the perfect
Silverberg, an experiment that nights,
the whole atmosphere on fire.
It might be a super intelligent AI that
accidentally or purposely destroys its
creators or things that we can't even
see coming right now or it's way simpler
species competitive enough
to take over that planet,
necessarily destroy it well competing
with each other for resources,
maybe there are runaway chain.
We actions in every ecosystem that once
set in motion are not fixable and so
once the civilization is powerful
enough to change the composition of its
atmosphere, they make that planet
uninhabitable 100% of the time.
Let's hope that that's not the case.
If the filter is ahead of us,
our odds are really bad.
What we can hope for.
This is why finding life
beyond earth would be horrible.
The more common life is in the universe
and the more advanced and complex it is,
the more likely it becomes that
a filter is in front of us.
Bacteria would be bad. Small animals
would be worse and intelligent.
Life would be alarming.
Ruins of ancient alien
civilizations would be horrible.
The best case scenario for us
right now is that laws is sterile,
that Europa's oceans are devoid of
life and the vast arms of the Milky Way
harbor only empty oceans
hugging dead continents,
that there are billions of empty planets
waiting to be discovered and to be
filled up with life.
Billions of new homes waiting
for us to finally arrive.
How likely is it that we'll find life
outside of earth that is similar to us?
Well, that depends on how many planets
there are out there and they're stars.
Goldilocks zone,
the area around the star where water
can be liquid because stars come in all
sizes and configurations.
This zone is different for every star
system and requires a little bit of
physics to figure out if
that sounds like fun to you.
This quiz from brilliant helps to break
down the maths for exactly how this is
calculated.
Brilliant.
As a problem solving website that
teaches you to think like a scientist by
guiding you through problems.
They take concepts like these,
break them up into bite sized bits,
present clear thinking in each park and
then build back up to an interesting
conclusion.
If you visit brilliant.org/nutshell
or click the link in the description,
you can sign up for free and
learn all kinds of things.
And as a bonus for courts,
cause I would viewers,
the first 688 people will also get
20% of that and your membership.
And if you do find life on other planets,
it made the wise to leave
them alone for a while.